de información reciente de la casa
blanca que está informando que en este
momento provide el presidente
estadounidense está hablando con bolado
bil selenski presidente ucraniano esto
después de que hace contados minutos
ucrania pues decretar al presidente
ucraniano decretara que el espacio aéreo
ucraniano está completamente cerrado
advirtió a aviones con civiles que pasan
cerca que pues corren el riesgo incluso
de ser derivados esto también después de
que pues varios corresponsales que hemos
visto en cadenas nacionales que están
allá tienen el centro de kiev escuchen
en sus transmisiones en directo también
estas explosiones que hemos venido
reportando desde que hemos venido
reportando acá a partir de información
de inteligencia del pentágono y de la
casa blanca de estos ataques que se
están dando no solamente ya en kiev sino
en las principales ciudades
estadounidenses era entonces una noche
bastante larga para el presidente yo
bailé el que tendrá obviamente llamadas
que no solamente con 12 mil celestes y
presidente ucraniano sino con otros
líderes del mundo de cara a esta reunión
esta reunión importante que tendrá
mañana en la mañana con el grupo del g7
para determinar precisamente cuál va a
ser la respuesta una respuesta que ya la
casa blanca en un comunicado y que ya el
presidente va a tener ese comunicado
dice que va a ser contundente y unida no
solamente con los aliados de la otan
sino con otros aliados de eeuu que se
apoyan a occidente y a estas movimientos
y avances militares que ha hecho la otan
en ucrania para tratar de defender la
soberanía
ucraniana el presidente de canadá de
hecho se introdujo se pronunció también
hace poco condenado los hechos
condenando este esta invasión a militar
está haciendo vladimir putin en ucrania
y pues es de resaltar también la frase
de el enviado especial para para ucrania
en las naciones unidas que dice que ya
es muy tarde para pensar en una
desescalada militar en este altercado
precisamente que tuvo el enviado de
ucrania en el consejo de seguridad de la
onu que terminó también hace unos
contados minutos en ese altercado que
precisamente puso fin a esa reunión es
enviado por ucrania le decía al
embajador de rusia que no había lugar en
el mundo para criminales de guerra
precisamente porque en medio y mientras
se daba esa reunión del consejo de
seguridad de la onu rusia estaba
invadiendo a ucrania y precisamente
lamentaba este hecho el enviado especial
de ucrania allá en el consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidades